foreign
[Music]
right now we are in UAE in Dubai service
center where we conduct field testing
for Tesla the climate here is is special
it's very warm so it's part of the
reason why we are doing testing here
we are focusing mainly on mileage
accumulation hot weather related tests
as well as product launch testing so we
like to test these cars here we also do
the same in Norway during the winter the
main goal of this test is to make sure
that these vehicles will survive at both
extreme conditions cold and hot will be
safe for every conditions we have in
between these two
we're actually driving per day between
250 and 400 kilometers
to make sure we have a long distance and
we stress the car a lot so now we finish
the supercharging which means we need
100 for this tour today and we run out
to jbj's to the mountain hopefully
everything goes good today let's see
I am collaborating with the field
quality engineering team from Berlin
we're testing model y here and at the
same time we have a US model X plaid
right now we're in Vassar Cameo it's an
Emirates about 150 kilometers from Dubai
we are at Double J's it's the highest
place of the UAE we have about 1400
meters above sea level here UAE is
perfect because the climate is
consistent it's always super hot extreme
humidity extreme heat earlier today it
was 51 degrees so pretty hot you don't
really find this climate anywhere else
in the world it can be very dusty one
day so we can have sandstorms or dust
storms it can also get very humid up to
80 90 humidity sometimes the hot climate
is really challenging for the vehicle
because it has to cool with the battery
the drive units and also it's really
important to keep the passengers cool so
we'll charge the car numerous times
we'll use the AC as much as possible
we'll use cabin over heat protection we
use all the features of the vehicle
pocket in the Sun for a long time we'll
charge it to superchargers why are we
using black cars because black absorbs
more heat so we want to take the car
that's most likely to suffer we're
trying to find everything that could
impact the customer from bumper to
bumper
here we are on the Mountain Road so we
have a steep incline which is really
good to test the chassis components for
example there's lots of twisty turns all
the way up the mountain it's a
continuous drive up so it puts a bit of
strain on the powertrain cooling air
conditioning all sorts of things going
uphill that cost a lot of energy and
it's turning into a lot of heat that's
perfect for testing the thermal system
don't worry but you've got a Hornet on
your shorts
he's gone
while testing conditions are pretty
intense the heat sunstorms it's a lot of
big bees around here also goats that
we're not used to see really often
[Music]
we are here right now in UAE because it
is the worst time to be in UAE it's the
hottest time of the year the weather is
no fun it's 50 degrees Celsius some days
you cannot go outside in in midday Sun
you will burn it's just too hot no one
wants to come here in the summer but
it's a great time to test a car in hot
climate
[Music]